so Rob our cover boy this week is
someone no one's ever heard of how did
we handle that I don't know i mean like
he's this young upstart apparently he
wants to run for president he's
notoriously camera shy so we thought
this was a good way to like introduce
the world to him our cover story this
week is about Donald Trump we think it's
a unique story because it takes you into
how he has built and run his business
but still it presented challenges he has
been on many other magazine covers and
so we went you know into the archives we
did a lot of photo research we found
this one photo of him I believe he's in
one of his casinos holding it looks to
be about a million dollars looking very
pleased with himself we tried a few
iterations there was one headline that
we liked which was how Trump became
Trump we tried to really small in the
bottom but thought it was a little
boring we tried it bigger we tried it
even larger but then it started to
overwhelm the photo a bit too much then
we tried his quote from the story which
we liked which was some day before I
kick the bucket somebody is going to get
what a great business I built then
Bryant one of our editors had the idea
of kind of doing more of a priority
treatment and so we tried something like
to defective trance clusive and then we
honed in on it a bit more and did align
Trump finally talks what kind of pokes
one hour resolves and kind of
acknowledges the fact that Trump is
obviously taking advantage of his
cultural profile so we have some other
great things in the issue this week I
thought our section on manufacturing had
some fun artnet it had an illustration
that kind of pulled an assembly line all
the way through the story so it kind of
pulled together our five stories on the
subject and we also had a really
interesting story about one of the
political parties in Finland which is
sort of a conservative Tea Party like
story which also had photos that really
helped you get to know the head of the
party which is known as the fins so I
think all in all it was a really great
with an issue yep